[Music]
welcome back to the mgm resort summer
league as the pistons lead the lakers 71
to 58 there's been a lot of stars here
we've spoken to a lot of stars including
kate cunningham but the selfie star of
the night is this young man here josh
boyman 11 year old josh boitman now
he was able to get lebron on his way out
to take a selfie now what did you do to
get lebron to take the selfie with you i
just screamed his name
i kind of have experience with lebron
i've been turned down for an autograph
and a selfie like three times already
and i just wanted to get it over with
and luckily it happened now when you
finally got the selfie and he threw up
his hands and he got in the picture with
you what did you feel like we saw you
jumping around i was i don't i don't
really know i just screamed i was so
happy for it to finally have happened
yeah and uh how long will this happiness
continue for you uh
probably the rest of my life
i mean at least a year all right i love
it and he signed matty's hat back there
behind me show your show us your hat
real quick there he is he signed that so
here we go he signed this hat here too
so lebron was doing work with the kids
they say true daddy loves the kids mark
jones but so does lebron james lebron
love
hey listen it really underscores guys
just
how
accessible how approachable
how warm
and how thoughtful i think a lot of our
players are in the nba especially our
stars we saw lebron there interact we we
saw him interact with other fans that
weren't on camera a moment ago russell
westbrook the same steph curry was here
earlier this week interacting with with
fans and just regular people i mean it
was a wonderful time and it's all part
of the summer league experience
and a lot of our guys come from a place
where
they know they're very grateful
i think that the character of the guys
in this league is as good as it's ever
been man
you got it yeah yeah and i think i think
usa my man littlest thing can shoot it
now 43 last year i believe
but i also think a lot of it go back to
05 and 06 and usa basketball when jerry
colangelo got
lebron and kobe and wade wade and those
guys to play
it became cool to play for the junior
national team
and the character of those kids needed
to mirror those of the seniors
and i really think the guys that come
into this league right now by and large
are we get to interview them during the
draft it's unbelievable how good of guys
these guys are